At just 21 years old, Daisy Ridley was far
from an established action hero when she was
cast as Rey in Star Wars: The Force Awakens.
In fact, she was all but unknown — her career
up to that point had been mainly minor roles
in small British productions, with no on-set
explosions or fight scenes to speak of.
So how did Ridley get herself in action-star
shape to join the sprawling Star Wars saga?
Let's take a look.
A lot of focus (and food)
Experts agree: when it comes to getting cut,
nutrition is far more important than exercise
in sculpting an eye-catching body.
In Ridley's case, the already slim actress
wasn't trying to lose weight for her role,
but rather bulk up to look strong and ready
to fight the First Order.
"I had to put on muscle.
So I was eating a lot.
And I love to eat, but it got to a point where
I was like, 'I feel sick.'
But someone's telling you to eat, telling
you to eat, and you're just like, aggh."
But a high-calorie diet isn't a license to
eat empty calories like ice cream and drink
beer all day — otherwise everyone would
be doing it.
Instead, Ridley ate a healthy high-calorie
diet consisting of foods loaded with protein,
which is an essential ingredient to growing
muscle.
Training as therapy
Ridley started her training just a few weeks
after she learned she got the role of Rey,
buckling down on a regimen of five-hour-a-day,
five-day-a-week workouts.
Speaking to Elle, Ridley said she came around
to a mindset in which the lengthy workout
routines felt like more of a blessed oasis
in her day rather than an unwelcome interruption
in her life.
"It became my solace.
It's the only thing structured in my life
right now.
Training is sort of a therapy session, I guess."
A combination of disciplines
While training for The Force Awakens, Ridley
chronicled her fitness journey on Instagram,
earning fans with popular "Fitness Friday"
posts that have since been deleted — but
live on through the archival efforts of her
online followers.
In the videos, you can see her engaging in
a little bit of everything in the gym, from
resistance training to tone muscle, to core
strength-building workouts.
She also engaged in activities as diverse
as kickboxing, rock climbing, and, of course,
tons of cardio.
The end result of this variety of work is
overall fitness and a body that's generally
muscular, with no one muscle group exaggerated.
After all, Rey isn't a musclebound warrior
— she's just a generally fit person, and
for the movie's sake, she needs to look like
it.
Personal trainers
The main trainer Ridley worked with early
on was Jack Graves, a former rugby player
— which may have something to do with all
the grueling cardio work that went into her
routines.
But while Graves did the work for Ridley's
general fitness, she also worked with more
specialized trainers for activities specific
to Star Wars — like swinging swords around
in close-quarters combat, which saw her training
with a stuntman and choreographer who also
helped design the fight sequences for The
Last Jedi.
And Ridley told Vogue those lightsabers are
heavier than they look, weighing in at about
ten pounds, so she really needed the conditioning:
"They’re really heavy.
[...] Three, four, five kilos?
And the weight’s very unevenly distributed."
A positive outlook
In one of Ridley's old Instagram posts, she
made a point about how what we see on Instagram
rarely corresponds to reality, and that her
fitness posts, while inspiring, hardly told
the whole story.
"I have a trainer urging me on in workouts
and I don't include all the times I say 'I
can't do it'."
What she did include, though, was positivity
and excitement — an enthusiasm for the work,
even when she wasn't at her best.
As one characteristic post read:.
"For anyone that's gonna try and correct my
form.
I KNOW it isn't the best, I've just started
doing sprint training so progressing all the
time!"
This sort of positive outlook matters, as
does knowing that just because you're not
at your best right now, it doesn't mean you
won't get better.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!